[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so slight changes
uh we have
um
hustle had some stuff he had to do so
it's just going to be incognito for
today
um acg if you want to pull up man pull
up the reason i don't really ask you a
lot to do stuff like this is because i
know you're like reviewing like 80 games
right now
you're bread and butter man i want to
take you away from it i know you busy as
it is with these these reviews and the
podcasting so i don't really try to hit
up
but i'll see you guys
[Music]
man acg let me make sure people can hear
me
shout out to acg with the hundred dollar
super chat as always i have nothing uh
of importance to say so
mass effect was the best mass effect i
actually really enjoyed mass effect 3.
that's just my thing man you know i
would definitely appreciate it
you've always been a real one and i
appreciate that
and uh you know we will talk in the
future and i appreciate you hitting me
with that uh that stuff this morning it
was a nice read
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
so
so
so
making the audios work what's going on
guys gaming out here coming at you
with uh the attic show man lord addicts
however you guys want to pronounce me
you know people keep telling me i need a
i need a i need to simplify my name
cognito people keep simplifying like
look look here here's the here's how it
goes i'm gaming addict but on iop i'm
lord addict because the the addict in
the gaming addict like
what what's funny is like people think
that i need to change gaming addict to
lord addict
oh like really yeah he was always
getting an addict before that like
i'm like
the attic part is part of my name so
yeah i'm called lord addict like i guess
they want me to be called lord gaming
addict i don't know oh no that's too
much they're doing too much they're
doing too look it's only one attic man
there's only one young wolf man this
ain't confusing this ain't rocket
science you know
according to some people it's it's a
little confusing man it's a little
confusing
so
thank you everyone for coming to
remember going to be having a great show
uh
sadly hustle he has uh he was doing some
work stuff i don't know he might jump in
later on in the podcast but right now
she's gonna be me incognito uh first off
i want to you know thank acg again for
the amazing support he always be showing
up man
acgb like showing up out of nowhere
sometimes
great great individual man great content
creator uh you know
even when we disagree about acg is
always one of those people you could
have a conversation
about why you disagree and i've always
enjoyed that about it so first off as
you guys can see we're gonna be talking
about xbox at the tokyo game show we're
also gonna be talking about should xbox
buy studios because just because they
can buy student obviously they can't
doesn't mean they need to buy studios
and then we'll talk about that quite a
dream working on a star wars title and i
feel like that's big because of
obviously the you know the wolverine
going on right now the the spider-man
and clearly star wars is part of the
brands that that company that disney
owned so i want to you know briefly go
into that but yeah first thing let's go
laura carney what you've been doing man
shelling man podcasting doing my thing
you know what i'm saying we just came
off that ilp this sunday fire we got to
shout out jimmy champagne in the crew
i actually talked to him about the the
friday thing which is funny he's like i
actually
really really like like movies like a
lot like yeah i like the movie lately
is like i never really have anyone to
like
use that outlet with you know what i'm
saying like right you know because for
the most part you know no one watches
movies like quad like i do and i think
because i haven't had that outlet it's
kind of died down
throughout the years so we got a five
dollar superchat from flame
sunday but here's some smoke why does
xbox need more studios if we're yet to
get anything from bethesda on xbox xbox
insider's right
yo
[Laughter]
you know with the 102 super chat i just
wanted to be acg oh man salute bro
you know you guys
yeah a little emotional because um not
for real like jake acg these are legends
in the game and for us you know coming
up you know you always aspire that your
peers respect what you do and we have so
much respect for both of them it's
extremely humbling we've seen you with
the banner bro you had the crest up bro
that's love
muslim and the man knows his pizza man
he knows his pizza
like i got so much love for this man we
we we finally struck down those evil
chicago lasagna having lords but now
much love jake valdino much love acg man
yeah i have no idea what it means to us
man on the road to 10k
yeah we're really close we're like like
like a little bit less than 100 away man
like you guys don't like i'm gonna
really try to push to have a to have ten
thousand subs by next ilp i'm a really
market you guys are gonna get annoyed
with me this week
it is what it is because i want to you
cog how would it be nice to start iop
this sunday like we have hit 10 000 subs
i i got like 30 codes in my x in my pc
that i might drop all the mat all the
[ __ ] like me and you know how i was
we had those talks when it was like 50
subs 100 subs and people ain't listening
and 25 we like yo
we was feeling the way we was like yo i
don't know man we got to see but we
loved it we stuck with it i know we're
not big number guys but for the for
whatever reason it does mean i don't
think just being looking forward to 100
10 000 subs just make you a numbers guy
like it's a milestone it's a goal yeah
it's just like
10 000 people really want to listen to
like if you really it's mind-blowing in
a way
and i'm definitely going to push that
man you guys are going to get annoyed
with me but just bear with me man we got
to hit that 10k because i want to go
into this sunday and i want to celebrate
10k because we'll probably hit 10k this
sunday but i want to wait another week
to celebrate man so you know we're going
to try to make it to that 10k sunday so
the first thing we're going to talk
about i want to save the xbox
at game
uh at the tokyo game show for last
because i do feel like that is next uh
that's next week so first thing let's
talk about is the quan of dreams working
on a star wars title let me ask you a
question cognito do you see
what them working on a star wars because
for those of you who don't know quantum
dreams generally works with sony and
they have and it's rumored that they're
gonna have a star wars title so to me
i'm already in a little bit of a panic
mode just a little bit because because
i'm like i'm like first it's wolverine
then spider-man then courtois and now
they might be working on now another one
of the students that they work close
with might be working on a star wars
game and i'm just like that's crazy
because if you think about it they're
the people that made um uh uh what's
that game called
troy first off let's let's get this out
of the way i'm mad excited for them to
be working on on a detroit like game in
the star wars universe i think that
could be very very beneficial to
everybody but at the same time it's like
cog we got to buy this on playstation to
look alike like i don't know though not
necessarily not necessarily because
didn't they they had a rock if i
remember they had a rocky
kind of not rocky but they they kind of
ended their relationship with their
stuff kind of going to pc and then there
was some legal stuff going on in that
studio that wasn't all on up and up or
what's going on i think it's david cage
in them so my understanding they're on
pci yes the relationship is there but i
am very curious if it will be
an exclusive situation that that i need
i need to do some research on that
because i i remember towards the end of
that relationship they kind of spread
their wings a little bit but it would be
interesting to see what you did you
think it's still because of the
relationship with sony in the past
they'll they'll keep that uh keep that
going i'd be very surprised if it wasn't
a
an exclusive like very surprised because
like to me
the proof is just there like besides
indiana jones which i think that might
have been done before
and you know i think sony is doing what
they can with that spider-man license
i'm still dying on that hill because to
me
they're getting a lot of these licensing
exclusive like couture the fact that
they got
knights of the old republic exclusive on
their platform when that debuted on the
xbox platform shows me enough that
they're not playing when it comes to
this stuff they do they got they got
they got their hands on the cookie jar
and they're not letting that go and to
me i feel like it's not going to end
there
i personally feel like sony is doing
what they can to lock down some of these
high popular
uh brands and they're trying to lock
them down because if you think about it
like imagine if they make like i don't
know what they maybe is start like to me
it's not gonna be jedi focused like it
wouldn't make sense to make a kind of
story oriented game that's playing as a
jedi in that type of gameplay like maybe
like be a political thing where you're
where you're in you know the the
republic or something like that i don't
know clearly that's speculation
but it's just like
[ __ ] if you want to play something star
wars related or if you want to play
something marvel related
sony's screaming from the rooftops we're
the only place to go what would you
agree with that now here's the thing
here's the thing i'm looking at some
some information on quantic you know
what i'm saying so it says they open the
door to more pc releases with the move
to self-publishing and this is a article
in pc game a while back it said they've
been a french studio primarily known uh
associated with assaulting with his
previous three releases heavy rain
beyond two souls detroit became human
they been putting stuff on pc
right and they said well what published
by solely and until recently until
recently exclusive to playstation
consoles that will change in the future
however as quantum dream says it's now
in a position where it could publish its
own stuff so that's what i'm saying like
the key is going to be
the self-publishing aspect and if
they're going to really go total
independence and if
this is a multiple there's a chance
there's a chance there is i'd agree with
you if they self-publish there is a
chance it just depends on how they got
their hands on those that license that
is true
right because now that what you call it
facilitates the relationship and they
kind of you know get back in bed with
sony on that then you know obviously it
could be what it be but it will be
interesting self-publishing it would
make more sense
to you know look you guys could
self-publish will help with some of the
marketing let's let's talk to our
friends over here and disney and get you
the star wars license it would make more
sense for them it's like the only catch
is you can't put it on xbox yeah we're
gonna see if they make a star wars game
that's automatically gonna make more
money for them because they have such a
high i.p
it's funny because i'm i'm a big fan of
detroit became human i really like that
game i thought it was graphically
impressive i know it's the walking
simulator we're not supposed to like
those games but i feel those games are
really well done the the it's real
choice real scenarios you remember the
demo where you got the the android on
the roof and you got to try to stop the
kit like the way cinematically they cut
their games and and in the actual
dialogue choices that could and the
things you could do in a specific time
slot it opens up a lot of possibilities
so i would like to see their little take
in the star wars provided that they
continue those style of games that
they're kind of known for what do you
think would you like that in that
universe i think they're going to
continue that style game because i
haven't played all of detroit
but what i played i really enjoyed
actually since i had this uh since this
brick ps5 i got this this giant handwave
man i don't even need to go to the gym i
just need to bench this thing wait what
happened to your ps5 yet jay was working
no no i'm saying it's so big i could
bench it oh you stupid oh you clowned it
all guys so you know since i got this
you know i might go ahead and uh
try my hat on again on um on that game
because when i saw it i enjoyed it i
really enjoyed those type of games and i
feel like um
as of right now
uh supermassive games is the king of
that and they don't they don't
necessarily make the best games in that
genre but until someone beats until dawn
they have made the best game in that job
until though
yeah so we got five dollars for
replicant if i butchered your name my
bad i'm all
over a quantum drink star wars game
single player narrative focus
[Laughter]
just go get something to eat
so you know i just
if this is if this is a multiplied
that's one thing but it like in terms of
xbox i am a little worried because it's
just like until we get more info
obviously we don't know
exactly what's going on but like i'm
going off of what i see cognito would
you say that it's fair to say that you
know based off court or being a timed
exclusive based off the relationship
they've secured getting spider-man an
exclusive getting getting wolverine and
exclusive that it's a good chance that
this game might be exclusive
it's a possibility i mean we can't rule
it out obviously we can't rule it out
you know again it's what we talked about
right well we we talked about pop
culture sony doing a phenomenal job of
realizing you know what's what's
important what a lot of casual gamers or
people who are not even in the gaming
would know and they do a phenomenal job
and we we've always we talked about you
know obviously xbox's deficiency in that
in that area and wanting them to improve
and stuff like that so look if it is
exclusive yeah it's it's another
you know feathering the cap to what
sony's doing and to them that is it's to
me small business you know get what
people will relate to what what people
who may not even pick up a video game
console would know who a spider-man or
wolverine the star wars mandalorian all
that stuff is pop culture and they got
their finger on the post gotta give it
up you know be cool because there is a
lot of rumors about a mandalorian um
game
it would be cool if they were able to
get their hands on that because i do
feel like right now
if
if they can't get access to certain of
these like mandalorian is so popular
off of one season i think they're on two
seasons i can't remember but they're so
popular off of this tv show that if they
could get their hands on a mandalorian
tv a game based on the tv show first i
have questions i have for you cog is
who's makeup who's making it and it
could be that it could be your number
one you're just one like
let me tell you right now i was on xbox
ever shout out to them special dick and
them we talk about a man lord game
because if you watch mandalorian it's a
video game bro it's literally a guy goes
to different planets taking care of this
kid protecting the kid you know seeing
these different enemy types and people
that you don't know a friend to follow
the game it's literally set up like a
game so for me
yeah let's see i mean there's so many we
got you know what i'm saying obviously
we you know we love our compulsion they
could be doing you know something in
that genre um i love me i love the
coalition you know i love their
graphical fidelity and stuff but this
you know i want actually one of the the
smaller ones like to get a shot like
like an exile or something somebody that
you
we that we or like double fine like
someone who we you don't really
associate with these big blockbuster
projects but are known for good game
development and good writing i would
love to see that well who would you like
to um see
first off
ac
they fighting over who's donating the
most man this must be what big money be
doing oh
shout out to acg i'm the biggest fan
jake lords know it
he's in the flex and he's like jake sit
down
this is big money man it's big buddy
i love the messiness between him and
jake dropping balls on your mom
we gotta get both of them on on the show
for real for real like hilarious he says
he's 80 1980 flexing he flexing
that's a bar dropping bombs on your mom
since 1980 we got 100 lions up here too
oh y'all showing love macho to build it
i butchered that we're going to move
right past that niner nation eagles down
we undefeated let's go i assume that's
football talk i said maybe nice
your favorites friday night football
remember how you used to go you can't
you keep mocking me i'm going to say
it's a wednesday night football
i knew you knew nothing about what's
going on when you said out loud i don't
know nothing about football
salute a gay what's up yeah so we was
talking about you know who you think
would be making a mandalorian game if if
one was in the uh well let me start off
this day before the xbox community comes
out because they get all mad with god we
don't need to copy sony you know and you
know don't pull off anybody we're not
saying that if a studio first of all
wants to do it and it's available by all
means but they got a ton man we got
ninja theory you got what i'm saying you
got playground you got a lot of people
just as long as they're fishing with
indicators in the schedule like i really
don't i don't really don't even care
provided it's not like
i don't know it's probably nobody i
would say like shouldn't do it but i
guess turn 10 turn 10 makes me think
like maybe that but who who would you
want
making a mandalorian coalition yeah
well you know that engine engine
okay look look there are they're all
conditions all right if if coalition
made one
i don't want it as gory as as gears
games but i do want that type of
gameplay from gears games but i don't
want it
to feel like
the main characters is like the weight
of a ship you know what i'm saying like
yeah
a little loose just not too much a
little loose and like here here me and
you always go back to back and you know
always say like look like i do feel like
you're entitled to you know you're just
one because at the end of the day like
there is a lot of
studios like where me and you bash at is
who would make it i think that's what we
bash at because you say i don't care who
does it i'm like no no we ain't going
there right
like i i definitely care who does it
like you know so all right so so let's
have some fun with it who
you don't want doing it i don't want
obsidian doing it i don't want exile
doing it
wait a minute i gotta stop you damn
besmirched a great name of obsidian why
can't obsidian make it
because i want up city and making with
the games i like obsidian to make i want
the making the rpgs that uh you know
what i'm saying i want them to stay in
there
it's not that they're not capable of no
i know i think they definitely could
make it
you can't do that to my that's my
hard-earned city that's my heart no no
city and i feel is the goat
and they're stable right now it's the
goat like but but the thing is is like
the more games that they that these
studios that microsoft purchased
continue to deliver we saw psychonauts
we saw
death loop like clearly they have a lot
of good studios in their
in their stable and i get it people want
to see what microsoft's making them do
but it's just like clearly when you play
something like death poop and you see
as you see and you see
and you see some of the you know uh the
cuts that clearly was took in death loop
or some of the a lot of the characters
look alike there's some that look like
crystals for some reason i don't know
what that's about like you clearly see
that you know there was some budget cuts
from that game like i don't know
obviously i'm not behind closed doors
i'm just looking from someone outside
looking in and to me it's just like if
they made that kind of quality game with
that kind of money that they had in that
game like there's no way that a studio
such as you know um
arcane is going to continue that type of
people act like they're just going to go
downhill you know what i'm saying like
they're going to make these type of
games then they're just going to drop oh
yeah well you know how it is they people
feel like as soon as xbox you know how
to go yeah and it's just like to me it's
like they're showing us this the quality
studios they make and the thing that i'm
telling them like oh you know they're
going to make them make this they're
going to make them make that they're
clearly making good games on a budget so
it's just like if even if microsoft kept
them on that budget they're clearly
kicking it out at the park already yeah
and to me that's what not to country but
that to me that's what is exciting about
this whole situation because
we know moving forward that
all these studios are going to have the
resources to do what they got to do
agrees with the debt no
i never said i agree you know maddie i'm
gonna have to i'm gonna have to get you
in a voice chat because because some of
the words i can't be saying on twitter
because i don't i i nee i need to hear
your reaction maddie mister
i never said that
first off you didn't you didn't watch my
review maddie you didn't watch my review
uh look like we do have some differences
in terms of
of death flu but you can even ask
cognito i agree with a lot you say i i
do agree with a lot you say i feel like
you know
just go watch my review i don't want to
spoil the game this is what this is
as an outsider this is y'all two being
bougie arcane fans and boujee arcane
fans competing in who has the better
mona lisa is it dishonored one decided
to that's all it says the game is great
y'all just being nitpicky because y'all
love these games as far as the pantheon
you can even ask cognito uh maddie for
like the longest time
i was here i was i'm not with death loop
i don't want nothing to do with that
because it didn't have the words
dishonored three on its name like and
see see
i guess maddie what i enjoy the most
about what we've seen in these type of
in death loop is it gives me hope for
maybe a dishonored three in the future
because i really enjoy the universe that
that game's took in place in um we got a
two dollar super chat from
look man let me let me say this off we
need song
okay when i butchered this whole damn
name
just say it it was your fault for making
your name this all right
cyphoponet podiak
ex initially off you off you all the way
off look man
okay it is we're going to move right
past it though
so so we got okay obsidian plus batman
go
um
why are we going why why why are we not
just going we're going to buy the
building and get that wb though why we
why we ain't doing that like wow what's
up i do feel like if anyone makes a
batman it needs to be rock steady but
that wasn't the question should have
said
use something with batman i say no
but all right
you don't you you are acting like you're
keeping obsidian locked
in my closet they ain't getting now bro
you can't have them only make these type
of games and nothing else it's like you
don't trust them to do anything else you
can't be that controlling man look they
locked in my closet they're making the
games i want them to play wow i want to
play and i'm gonna be selfish stay in
that club culture i thought we was
cultivating a nice environment
where the studios could do what they
want to do that's what we were told at
it now you're changing the rules look
man i don't mind if they make other
stuff as long as they make stuff i want
to play oh yeah it's selfish yet okay i
got a job i already see what this is
i do have faith in them but when it
comes to something like batman like in
terms of what they've played i know they
could do something like that but i don't
know if it would be accepted because
people
because an output license but a batman
like they do make an rpg
like
when they go there they go are they
gonna have like like batman has guns
like how are you acting like they can't
do anything outside of western rpg that
hardcore pure rpg that you love like we
have to see them spread their wings
[ __ ] okay
you selfishly what the games you want
from them and only that bro some of the
best ideas of birth from studios that
you wouldn't necessarily
remember even on the sony side remember
they got gorilla and what would have
said they would have did something like
horizon zero dawn and all that stuff you
got to let people suck a punch let them
grow look at ghost of sashima before
that it was okay okay look i i i get
that as long as it's an rpg i'm good oh
my gosh it's gotta be an rpg man gotta
be an artist shop addict
shop
you work at xbox game studio addict
no look it's more of like you it's not
necessarily a sweatshop because i'm not
pg's out okay
i guess i am making you make it okay
i'll give you that but you know what
that's okay that's okay
that's fine
because when they make me the bombs that
i want to play
i can't tell them to make something else
i feel you you've got your western rpgs
online i feel you you like yo don't mess
with my joints this is what we brought
you here it's just funny to me that they
are just locked in the closet forced to
make western rpgs all day for you i just
think it's hilarious
no they locked in my closet they locked
in my closet look look we completely
diverted this entire yeah
let's get back the whole point of you
know quanta dreams is i personally feel
like you know i don't want
sony being the only place to go to play
you know disney's title games that's my
only thing i just don't want that kind
of scenario hold on i gotta ask you a
question because this is a big thing in
the community so let's just say
hypothetically
this is exclusive to sony right
so
the the consensus in some washington
city some people in the xbox community
feel that uh microsoft should not match
this like they should continue to do
their diverse lineup of games don't
worry about these style of games at all
like what do you feel if that's the case
if again now it would be kotor
it would be the spider-man stuff
and then another star wars if it's the
school like do you what do you think
what do you say to that that don't xbox
shouldn't worry about that
i do think they should worry about it
because to me
like we're not talking about some like
yeah they got the uh what's that game
that uh attack all humans uh okay the
the
the martian game i can't remember
i'm sure i'm sure people in the chat
about the clown on me but it's okay
but like to me when it comes to it like
my biggest thing is just like
if you let these big titles leave enough
you're going to end up getting to the
point where you know
no sure you're gonna have good titles
but no one's gonna really know
like it's not gonna be to the point
where everyone else has like you can't
beat spider-man right now you know what
i'm saying like you can't like couture
sure i don't i don't think i think
couture is different because i do think
it is it is a
what's wrong looking for it's a um
it is a
a star wars game but i wouldn't go as
far to say it's like a really popular
star wars game like the hardcore might
love and adore this game but i don't
know if like it will pick up like a
massive new audience if that makes sense
to you yeah they will hustle i'm like
how's it tell me dear hustle
whatever that's what it was
i broke something i'm trying to i'm
trying to get the green screen off oh
okay oh what you do is go to on the
virtual joint hit the stop wait next to
the video icon a little arrow hit the
choose virtual background you can check
you can put that to none get that out of
there
wait set it again for me so you know it
says stop video on the zoom joint the
little arrow right next to it just hit
that and then you should see a little
choose virtual background you should be
able to get that joint off of it if you
want yeah so we got hustle in here man i
had to change the layout a little bit no
doubt
[Laughter]
alvin it was insomniac's choice to go
for uh to go for both spiderman and
wolverine sony just gave the okay if
studios came to phil and wanted to do a
certain game filled with cosign studios
studio has to want to salute lords i get
that and i do agree with you they have
to want to but to me
i feel like if microsoft truly wanted a
comic book hero they'd have one by now
it's been years since they got
spider-man maybe they're going to be a
little let me ask you guys do you think
they might be a little bit more
aggressive now since they have
spider-man and wolverine we'll go with
we'll go with hustle because he ain't
better yeah go hustle yeah
they need to be
on one hand i feel like they need to be
um it was an interview a little while
ago where phil spence is pretty much
said he doesn't want to do things like
sony does right
like like their version of an uncharted
so on and so forth
but you can't just let your competition
just take all of the marvel things and
if they do take all the marvel things
all right cool let's take the dc stuff i
don't know if y'all mentioned that
earlier but just all right you look you
get the other guys at that point if you
go on if you're going to work just get
the other guys because this this is
getting bad like if somebody controls
the whole marvel universe i'm a marvel
dude if they control the whole thing
then i'm definitely going to need a
playstation 5 or playstation from there
on out at that point man but
you know
i i think um
i think if
they have to make a move they got to
hurry up and and make that and i'm sure
feeling them they're working behind the
scenes they they're probably scrambling
like on a sunday morning yes sir hustle
they saying if if xbox does that that's
copying sony we don't they don't want
them copy that's what i hear don't copy
them they should not do even if it's a
deficiency that it's copying if you make
a game in that lane
man why hey look
they can get to doing all that all they
want
copy them dawg it's okay like look
competition like this is what you need
that type of competition for
hey look i don't we don't know what
indiana jones is going to be and i don't
want to throw the rail too much but
y'all know my favorite franchise is
uncharted like i'm trying to my favorite
game we don't know what indiana jones is
going to be but i hope it lives up to
something like an uncharted game right
it's just but we need that competition
anyway come on you know
yeah yes sir yes the biggest question
that i do have for you guys is let's say
that they don't
go
for the comic book stuff
what do you think would happen
if the games that they do produce really
well let's say that you know a vow comes
out nine five on metacritic everyone
loves it sells well do you think an
avowed at nine five on metacritic sold
well love people love it maybe not just
as much as god no hell it's love just as
much as skyrim but
spider-man 2 comes out popping at a 9-1
but it's a bigger pill so it reaches
more people what do you think happens do
you think that's enough to you know
because to me that's what i'm looking at
and avowed at the height isn't going to
reach as many people as a spider-man 2
good game
i feel what you're saying and that's
that's the age-old argument right it's
the it's this is where
again the the hardcore gamer that you
know it understands what a quality game
is right we understand the skyrims and
all this stuff and fallouts and all
these iconic ips and gaming spaces that
do well
but there's also something to be said
right when you see like something like i
said the spider-man thing or you know
the star wars thing when those games are
good
it hits different we've seen the success
of spider-man you know for for a
playstation i think
they're not mutually exclusive i think
you know you can do both you you can
literally
yeah have this great diverse lineup
which they're doing a fantastic job
let's be clear xbox is doing a fantastic
job with the indies
big budget games
aaa games they're doing a phenomenal job
all we're saying or at least i'm saying
it's just deficiency like look at look
at something that you can improve on and
the example i use since people are all
emotional about superhero games all of a
sudden you can't do that that's copying
you know my thing is look at your
fighting games where are they right you
see what i'm saying so so if they make a
fighting game now is that copying sony
you see what i'm saying like all i'm
saying is it's
it's okay to be objective and critical
at your roster it's like a team right
muscle like you get like yo we need more
rebounding right we need more outside
shooting right we got all these we got
scorers we got you know what i'm saying
like it's just about being a
well-rounded studio you know a
development house that's all i'm talking
about so for me i think
they should do it no problem just to
interrupt you real quick i think your
point is like look it's not about copies
about being competitive if you don't try
to take these avenues that sony's taking
to make their brand more appealing then
you're never going to get more appealing
than they are because they have these
hot items i mean look look they i mean
obviously master chief went in
in fortnight but uh alloy has been in
fortnite the chick from horizon zero
dawn
uh kratos has been in there so like you
know they're very open to putting as
many stuff into these high appealing
areas that way when these games come out
oh i played with this dude on fortnight
but then they play god of war and
realize it's not a fortnight
game and let's be clear like i want to
give credit before i go i want to give
credit like they are doing a phenomenal
job with a diverse lineup of games
they're really killing it on the indies
we know about western rpgs they got that
in spades right and multiplayer games
cooperative games they've got that i'm
not going to take that away from them
again we just talk about just rounding
up filling up a little edge here with a
game here and a game there that's all
i'm talking about but guys
yeah um i don't really think i have
anything to add on to that point but
whoever said that oh they're copying go
ahead and copy sometimes sometimes you
gotta copy the smartcare homework and
switch up your answers just a little bit
and my views are not the same on this
don't man don't go it don't let this man
get you out there
go copy the homework man do it let's go
but but i only say that because you like
a lot of people were talking about when
microsoft were buying these studios
talking about having a monopoly and all
this stuff a stranglehold on it like you
need versatility when it comes to like
most types of games like i love
uncharted but i just don't want one type
of uncharted um i love like wrestling
games like i'm playing no mercy and
stuff but i just don't want one type of
like wwf game um because if we get that
type of thing not just saying that
insomniac would get complacent but they
could you know they very well could
actually very well play and they could
very well turn into a wwe 2k 20
situation not saying that it will i'm
just saying that it could be like we see
madden every year we see madden every
year they ain't had competitions since
2k five terrell is on the journey
amazing so you need i know right for
twenty dollars oh man you know what yeah
but but you but you need that though
like you you need that type of like
one has to push the other one yes and
when it comes to a situation like this
cog regardless of what the
people say on the internet man they said
stop asking for my hashtag just one stop
asking for superhero games if you make a
[ __ ] game everything's copying now
like that's the new thing now i'm like
all right this is what we do with it
let me get some of these super chats uh
we got to find all the superstars from
dylan b
hey coggin addict uh did y'all ever play
kung fu chaos on the original xbox this
could be a fun game to bring back uh
this was before you joined us i don't
want you thinking dylan just let you out
of the super chat high school i was i
was listening on the way home i'm
listening so uh i've never played that
um that was fun to be honest with you
like it was neither i played halo or
fable on the original xbox i didn't
really like gravitate anything around
that total aor game say guys stop making
the podcast it's copying others
he's got a point that's what i'm talking
about bro that dude dudes just let me
let's let's keep it a buck addict attic
show
a lot of dudes is in their feelings when
other platforms show success in a genre
they don't have right so now they don't
want they j studio they favorite to do
that because it's an admission see
that's what they say this is this is
these are men with emotion that's all
i'm trying to win i'm trying to have the
best diverse lineup going right i don't
care about all these feelings of but
dudes being they feelings and i'm
telling them
it's about being competitive and not
having a brand die out eventually and if
you're not trying to fight them on their
lawns
and you try to wait for them to go on
the streets you can hit them with their
car
and they got they running out there they
got your girl kotor with the two come on
man
it was on your console it debuted first
like could you imagine like any a
nintendo first party that debuted on a
switch now on playstation xbox
regardless if it's just if it's timed
exclusive it's just a bad look it's not
even multi-plat right that's what i'm
trying to say like that the kotor
situation is letting you know sony's
very aggressive in this space you're
gonna need to compete otherwise they're
gonna have a monopoly on this particular
genre that's not healthy especially in
fighting where they got evil
let's be real like when you go to evil
when people you know don't go it's like
you see the sony controllers a casual
person will think that is the only place
you can do x y and z you see what i'm
saying and you don't want the mind share
to be controlled that much where you're
not even in the space that's what i'm
dressed look at the concept that we have
now star wars looks like a lot of these
are being on playstation comic book
games a lot of these being on
playstation so the casual person's going
to
to to gamestop and he's asking yo that
wolverine game only on playstation yo
that's that spider-man game only on
playstation in the back of his mind if i
want to play stuff i see on tv it's only
going to be on playstation and that
could be farthest thing from the truth
why do you think these companies spend
millions and millions of dollars doing
advertising because they want to
subconsciously trick the casual mind and
if they can that call of duty symbol at
the end of the commercial means it's
only on
on playstation i agree remember they
should tell us that with destiny right
they people when dusty you know first
came out with you know ps4 and stuff
people would think it was exclusive to
to place it they didn't realize that it
was an xbox version and marketing does
go away it goes a long way with the mind
share and the casual base all right so
let's get a this man this this dude he's
super chat just so i will butcher his
name
uh the uh the cephalopenic uh
i like how you butcher it every time
look it is what it is man we
you know i can't do it oh my god it gets
worse
look bad the axe initiative
he here's another question man the the
flash
plus the initiative what are you talking
about we're going there hustle what do
you think about the flash
plus the initiative
i'd say pick a better superhero and uh
thank you for your super chat oh damn i
look i'm gonna keep it real with you i'm
getting ready with you i mean if you're
gonna pick up
that's yeah dc guy i know that's a dc
guy oh he's a volvo head girl body
karate i mean no yeah but it's not just
that no no okay if the initiative is
gonna pick pick a team first of all we
gotta see if they can do a third person
game but if they're not gonna pick a
team yeah i think that's
the game they're doing is the first
person right now
perfect yeah that's that's the drone
wait no but no no if they are going to
do a superhero game i would say wonder
woman first
i would say wonder woman to try to
redeem because apparently the last movie
wasn't too good but i would say do
wonder woman first and then that'll push
them out there oh you talk about like in
terms of pop culture popularity yes oh i
can't because the flash i couldn't he
said he's not cooking right now he's not
high right now not at all
like suicide squad they they want it but
i got you
all right so then we got a uh a super
chat from
god god the blessed one
dc ain't the response to marvel my
nephew don't even know who batman is but
he knows rocket and grout group
market uh marvel is whitney dc ain't an
xbox win i'ma be honest he does have a
point there and let me let me point out
why he's got a point there
the reason that
it makes so much sense for uh for sony
to really be friendly and get these
these marvel ips is because marv was
popular not saying dc is not popular i
know you guys are you guys are typing
there in the chat say no we're not
saying dc's not popular but we're saying
that marvel has done a better job
building up their brand in the in the
movie universe oh yeah that dc has
that is automatically going to make it
more appealing for people to want to
play as those characters than it would
be for someone want to play marvel
that's why like you only really see
batman out there because besides i would
say batman is just as popular as a lot
of the marvel characters because of
batman but as far as that's because his
movies his movies have been one of the
only ones that's actually hit so we got
to find all the super chat from jared
mack all held the iop
showing support for the lords uh jared
mack always being here manchester united
appreciate you always hello yeah
for real
he got me to the lighthouse at the shout
out about salute oh you got to the
lighthouse last night yeah yeah you got
me right after yes is this a destiny
talk oh yeah well that that one sentence
is it uh okay real quick before we move
on let's go um
god the blessed one um i want to respond
to your stupidity oh yeah get him get
him yeah yeah that's that's see that's
your fault that that's your nephew
what is it listen listen listen i i
gotta put a little heat on you a little
bit cause i'm gonna listen cause i'm my
uncle as well
right now sitting in my closet i got all
five seasons of the 90s x-men i got all
the episodes of the joint
uncle ricky what's that oh you don't
know about this man your father used to
watch this when he was kids
and we went over the whole thing but
yeah just gotta educate the kids man
that's all that is that's it this is
gonna educate the youngest man
now i feel like i feel you on that i
mean i mean i still think they're big
was like yo that's your fault
that's all i love
i i think i think like
i think what the biggest issue we have
is like a lot of kids don't show
interest in some of that stuff like
their friends are playing fortnite
minecraft roblox like like a lot you
know you might have a nephew or you know
a younger brother that might respect you
as a person to actually talk about stuff
like that but a lot of these kids that i
see like that's my brother's age younger
they're like if it's not the stuff i'm
talking they have the added world that
at the end of the day like a lot of
these things don't appeal to them like
you know you know you see a lot of
people that's why spider-man's so one is
be so we're gonna get to that okay we
see a spider-man like a lot of people or
they really gravitate towards spider-man
because he's such an iconic
character that appeals to a lot of
different people yeah so we gotta find
all this picture from uh uh thanos uh
threatened rose so i don't know man
we're gonna move past that
screw dc xbox needs to jump on the manga
anime hype manga is beating the bricks
off usa comics
i'm gonna disagree with you man i really
enjoy anime but i know cognito wouldn't
know anything about anything that
anything was me made but
but cognito doesn't recognize that these
things are popular
and if they are popular cognito they're
popular but i don't think it's the same
popularity like
i agree with you that they need to make
something like that if they start
actually budgeting and putting good
money behind anime games but there's
very few anime games that i feel is
worth your money at launch a lot of them
is just cash back on titan thing that's
that's one of them because i feel like
that's a good game that was designed
around the world of attack on titan but
there are certain games
you shouldn't think about it because
it'd be copying
no someone did say someone just say uh
anime fighting games are goaded and they
are like the dragon ball fighterz is a
very popular game and see i'm not
talking about stuff like that like we do
head-to-head fighters
microsoft needs as many of those as they
can get i don't even play that i don't
know so but at the end of the day it's
just like you know
look just look at it from that
standpoint animate just animate let's
talk about anime for a second sony's
bought that from a different perspective
i don't think that has anything to do
with actual
you know buying like making games but
these relationships they're making
because of fundamentation because of
crunchyroll they can leverage these
relationships to the next big game let's
say you know if you don't see the
pattern you see the pattern yeah
okay the same thing they did with the
marvel universe
microsoft needs to do stuff like that i
know they have a really good
relationship with nfl like they need to
start reusing these relationships they
have to make games to their platform
that's a more wide appeal than just halo
gears of forza like and i know like
we're not going to say that they're not
making more ips because they are and i'm
not saying that these ips aren't going
to be good because i feel like a lot of
them are going to be good but i'm saying
how many of these big ips that that's in
development even something like elder
scrolls 6. do you guys honestly think
elder scrolls 6 is going to have more of
a wide appeal than something like
spider-man alex goes to alex 46
at the end of the day we issues seen an
elder scrolls since 2011.
true a lot of the newer audiences
probably don't even know what this game
is
and i'm talking about the people growing
into the ecosystems the people coming
into the gaming industry right because
miranda has seen other scores for
probably three or four years no you talk
about from a generational stuff yeah
that's right i understand that i
understand that so let's see here let's
get uh
a five dollars richer from uh from
rubber knob i think i it's man thank you
guys for people who put their names in
something i can pronounce i love you
guys man i love you guys morning lords
we need a snyder's cut dc game that
would be that would take off a snyder's
cut dc would be like 500 hours long
so
let's
let's get back and um yeah acg said
elder scrolls is way bigger than
spider-man i agree with you i i agree
with you and i disagree with the acg you
know hit me up in dm's because i don't
want this i don't want to keep these
people up too long uh so we got a ten
dollar superstar from evan washington
once again thank you guys for making
stuff i could read thank you
xbox
it uh ignores the superhero trend for
now from 2018 to
uh we got 22 studios i'd rather than
focus on making games the teams want to
make on their own that way no licensing
issues in the future and i agree with
that i do i'm not saying that they have
to do nothing but make these type of
games i'm saying that as like
i don't like a comic book that has
relevancy would go a long way and it's
like acg said that he thinks elder
scrolls six is bigger than spider-man i
say that in the video game industry i
would say that's a hundred percent facts
but we're trying to get people that's
not in the industry to come into the
industry and i feel like in that terms
spider-man blows elder scrolls out of
the water when it comes to not in the
gaming industry in the gaming industry a
lot more people probably
you know they really love elder scrolls
over something like spider-man but not
in the gaming industry those people have
no idea what elder scrolls is you know i
understand
so then we gotta fight a lot of super
chat from god the blessed one i was
showing my nephew batman versus superman
he thought batman was a villain i tried
to school him but he didn't care if
barbara he if it ain't marvel uh he he
waited
so we gotta fight on super chat from uh
[ __ ] j hopefully xbox will buy wb and
get the license that yeah maybe cog will
be happy superhero games are and
fighting listen i'm happy now i just
want them to be great let's go for let's
go for greatness like why we gotta why
we can't why we gotta be settled for
mediocre you know what i'm saying but
i'm with you jk like i'm that's all i'm
saying let's just go for it baby we got
them it's not like they don't got the
resources yeah they they like they don't
got the brand right so that's all i'm
saying they shouldn't be getting
outmaneuvered in certain situations all
i'm saying i think the biggest thing is
is you can have as much money as you
want if you don't have the relationships
to get the stuff you want it's harder to
get it like for instance keep letting
your opponent make relationships with
all the pop culture things then you're
going to put yourself in a bad position
you know what i'm saying that's what i'm
saying i'm trying to prevent them being
locked out of pop culture genres like
that that's what i'm saying i'm sorry so
let's uh we gotta fight all the super
chat from uh uh big cloud gaming uh
definitely everyone in the chat go check
him out he's making great sony content
he's literally probably the only sony
content creator i watch regularly and
that's not capping
and i'm not saying nothing against any
of the other sony content creators but
he's got a lot of you know good
information that's in his stuff uh
what's up brother salute
see also big cloud shout out to you sir
he also has a great interview with uh
one of the lady the mexican chews
daughters
actual devs themselves very very high
quality
all right so let's let's go ahead and
move on a little bit we we definitely
stayed on that topic way too long but
it's okay it was good good natural
conversations that i'm okay with that
let's talk about xbox there's a lot of
acquisition rumors going around uh
people think microsoft's buying the
world i don't know what's going on there
just because it's like we said earlier
just because you have the money don't
mean you have the relationships to make
something happen uh and a lot of these
companies that people are saying they're
buying they're all public
so it makes things a lot harder to do
something like that when it comes to
public owned companies we're not going
to go into any logistics on that because
i got clowned on a couple weeks ago for
that i'm talking about something that i
don't know nothing about and i stated
multiple times i didn't know anything
about that but we're going to give it
talking about stuff we don't know
nothing about let's go so let's let's
talk about
do you guys personally we're going to
start with hustle think
microsoft needs to invest anymore do you
think they need to show fruit to get
that kind of you know good will from the
from the gamers to then purchase more to
so like to me right now the biggest
issue is
they keep buying studios and buying
studios but people are like yo chill we
want to see the games to show you can
make these games with these studios
before you continue to purchase stuff
how do you feel about that hustle
all right hey cognito i know you're a
football guy you'll appreciate this
reference let's get it you know where
i'm from you know i'm from dc right baby
football it's good xbox to me they are
turning into the
washington football team
of the big three and what i mean by that
is daniel schneider who's out this way
out there in landover maryland
all these big agent free agents and then
the team really wouldn't perform now
my solution is well first off the xbox
buy new studios and acquire new studios
if rockstar is going to save it you get
them but we're going we're going to just
slide this aside no they shouldn't they
should either invest like sony does sony
to their credit playstation their credit
they're not a cultivate talent they've
cultivated all these different studios
we've got all these classic titles and
we possibly have a new classic title in
canada canaan bridges spirits which i'm
gonna be playing a little bit later
after we're finished here so the second
they learn how to cultivate talent they
they're good they got the money too too
they got the money and they got the
capital to actually caught the va talent
and make new studios should they buy i
would like for them to buy like sega and
stuff like that but yeah should they nah
they just they they should have
three no let's say they should have four
more initiatives they got the money for
it they got the money to make four more
versions of that and if i'm them
let me not die today y'all yeah yeah
stay alive we need you
if i if if i'm microsoft i will put that
money right back into the company man
like
you got to understand they already they
got bethesda they got they got the whole
xenomex like do they really need do they
really need any more i would argue that
they need something new something fresh
because everybody's working on
everything as it is but if i'm them you
know i'm building up a whole new team
i'm building up all right yeah cool we
know them games is there
but if it were me i get like i probably
try to get like a cool little double a
studio or whatever the case makes they
got double a studios too so if i'm them
i'm building up from what they're at
that point we're drafting the talent
from with them because we see uh in the
lab studios yeah and we see the
reception that canaan is getting right
now so if if if it was me and i know
what i'm saying i'm gonna drill that
point home it was me
you build up from what then dawg like
you gotta like listen the golden state
warriors wasn't like the dynasty that
they were true thanks to steve kerr they
did they did cop durant though
i'll wrap it up with this sports
reference mark jackson put that whole
team together oh for sure however
stephen curry executed the whole thing
yeah they got kevin durant i think i
know what i'm talking but they got that
kevin durant but does that and all that
already so they don't they don't need to
kept in the rack
i feel you though [ __ ] i appreciate that
though it's all good i'm glad i folded
it but i mean i'm a different from the
homie hustle but that's the thing
i know you're going with it with
cultivation i understand your overall
point and that that point is there's
validity there right you you want to
cultivate talent you want them to grow
you know it's not just all about buying
stuff and then not having quality
produce fruit i feel you on that part
the thing i still think they still have
to
you know acquire more is because
at the end of the day if their goal is
game pass if their goal is all these
devices cloud pc what have you right
they want to be on every tv toaster
refrigerator whatever it is you're gonna
need studios you're gonna need a whole
bunch and to me there's still three
that's why it goes back to the wb stuff
again for me because it's like there's
still three deficiencies we talked about
the pop culture stuff we talked about
the fighting game stuff and also if you
really want to be real they have a
deficiency in um like kind of kitty
family friendly like that nintendo lane
right so they don't have enough of that
right so to me they still need to be in
acquisition mode especially if sacha's
throwing all this money behind phil and
all this stuff to get them out there so
i say yeah i say you know go go at it at
the end of the day i will say this
though and this is where i think you and
king are kind of on the same boat with
the um as far as acquisition i think it
it's more beneficial for them to get
publishers at this point because matt
booty's plate is full it's like you got
23 or whatever it is that you have
it's really getting full and at the same
time that's why the cinemax deal was
great because bethesda themselves like
they were very self-contained they were
already operating as their own you know
i'm saying ship under control so that
integration is easy if you're just
getting people who don't have that
publisher gone then that's a lot of
responsibility and then you know we
would definitely want that care and that
cultivation that you're talking about so
that's where i'm at with it so
do you have anything to say about that
yeah you want to respond to that hustle
no no no that that that's actually a
great point like with um like bethesda
you know all those students they can
kind of police themselves so that
wouldn't be work on that booty um i
guess capcom
because y'all want y'all to correct me
on that so capcom would be yeah i think
that would be ideal for that let's just
they can kind of run their own stuff too
yeah i ain't gonna say no gecko
i don't think a lot of people would
right exactly
you spoke on fighting games earlier yeah
the only real
thing about fighting games that i may
have an issue with is
all right man
what cool but
i don't know
but we got to think about the whole i
got you yeah cause i was like i've been
playing them street fighters
maybe that's why that that's not gonna
hit me the same but right like i get it
um but they got killer instinct um if if
i add microsoft though
and i know sony has done this
um you make your own super smash
brothers so you get all your xbox ideas
i can see that
you know i should like they got the
characters to do i would even that makes
the most sense i would even like that i
would even bite a little your swag a
little hustle you find everybody that's
ever worked for that team that's making
super smash brothers and you hire them
you make a you make an exact duplicate
of that game
[Laughter]
no i'm not saying i don't mean exactly
but you guys do what i mean you just you
make a competent game in that brand
because i feel like some people try to
do that and they don't do it very well
so we got a 10 super chat from lord
starkiller
x xs x01 hopefully microsoft can acquire
either wb
uh wb
games or take two interactive or ubisoft
two other possibilities could be capcom
or asbo i think um
i definitely butchered that last night
a sobo is definitely a possibility
i think wb might happen in the future i
don't know if that happened now take two
is in my dreams
and uh ubisoft is in my dreams as well
can you imagine if
listen the day that they about take two
i hope i'm by my phone that day though
cause that you thought the but that's
the you thought the xenomax joint is
crazy like that yeah
yeah twitter is doing more than breaking
that day i'm a car i'm gonna have a
welfare check on jack move i'm gonna
have a one foot check on uh
you guys know man you guys know i i
didn't mean what i said that okay you're
clearly a mispronounced you're good
you're good you're good so uh what are
you doing you got a two dollar stripper
from carlos he says xbox sleeping on the
smaller studios death store i agree they
do need to pick up a couple more of
those
i'm not gonna hold you i think two
people made that i think two people made
that story from that mistake and that's
the joint that i want to try that's like
the legend of zelda like version of like
xbox game or whatever i definitely got
to try that i saw a ton of people
playing i just haven't played it yet um
yeah yeah you know
i i hope uh look listen listen listen
like y'all know my feelings on it man i
feel like they don't need to buy no more
but if you but if you see something
there like if you see that listen
you gotta pull up it's coming bro it's
comfy season you gotta go pretty much
what you're saying so he's like yo like
they don't need to buy anything but if
it's there and you could touch it
yeah if you if you see you know if you
see your envelope full of money on there
sometimes you gotta pick it up here's my
stance
i don't think anything western they need
to leave that alone no take two nothing
like that they need to leave all that
stuff away
look that that's fine but the the point
of game pass the point that they're
getting destroyed is worldwide they have
no eastern appeal if you can't buy
eastern studios don't even mess with it
if like you know obviously sega if sega
came up you can touch it grab it you
know
you know but but
anything over there that's what you need
to really focus on i don't think like to
me you get ubisoft you're just buying
more western studios for the most part
you buy tank two you're buying a lot
more western studios for the most part
they bought bethesda which is one of the
most m rated western studios you could
get they don't need no more of those you
know that we need capcom good square
enix good you know we're talking about
giant publishers uh you know sega good
you know there's a lot of other
just regular developers over there but
it feels like to me microsoft's not
looking for studios they're looking for
publishers because they want a
publishing arm to monitor those studios
because they don't want to do it so you
know
let's do that man let let's get some
more eastern market missed walker i know
i say that a lot love that studio want
lost odyssey to want you know me and
maddie we love that franchise lost
odyssey needs a sequel
and
let's do it let's get those games out
there because i just partially feel like
double downing on a western market
something they don't need they need more
pill in the eastern market because when
xcloud starts coming out they're going
to want those those eastern games in
that game pass to appeal to that market
you know like by by second put persona 6
in game pass see how quick those
subscriptions go up across these that's
just my opinion on that matter but let's
see
let's talk about
the the elephant in the room which i
guess is a small elephant because a lot
of people don't care but you know let's
talk about tokyo game show
there has been a little bit of rumors
going into the tokyo game show talking
about whether or not we should be hyped
for it that's
on everyone in the chat and it's on the
individuals in the in the panel so my
question to you guys is
do you think that we've gotten to the
point with game pass to be more diverse
as possible and just getting more you
know different types of diverse genres
in the game pass to make it more
appealing to to to kind of you know be
appealing to everyone and not just a
certain amount of consumers do you think
that this is a show
that is important that microsoft should
start focusing on let's start on cognito
i mean tokyo is something they always
got to improve on right that's something
they always you know historically have
never been strong there so
you know for me
i always try to keep realistic
expectation though we're talking i mean
they're an american company they're
trying to improve it's never really been
the greatest thing but they've made
strides i feel like this generation
they've come out you know when you do
things like getting yakuza like a dragon
launch on your you know exclusive even
if it was time it was a big deal you
know we see the relationship with sega
games going into game pass and stuff
like that that's good you know i think
they've already set expectation i think
greeny his tweets were kind of like you
know
calm down don't look for another crazy
crazy
just to clarify though he is the same
person that told us not to not to go
crazy when it came to the uh the uh the
video game awards and they showed
perfect [ __ ]
i just think what it is i think he sees
a team
and he wants it on like a six bring it
down right and they know the community
can get wild with the speculation and
stuff like that and acquisitions it's
all the stuff we talk about
for me
it's simple you know get some game pass
deals of you know eastern title japanese
titles that are very popular over there
the biggest one the elephant in the room
has got to be persona it's got to be
they've got to figure out a way to get
this title on the platform we've seen
phil talk about it we've seen him
mention the title by name i can't
imagine it's not something that they
don't want to do and to me anything else
on top of that is just gravy like so
just simplify it keep your presence up
you know obviously they're doing better
this generation and it was not saying
that this they're doing massive over
there but look get the game pass thing
popping and get some more titles to get
that diversity up with japanese games so
how do you feel hustle do you feel like
this is something they should really
focus on or do you feel like maybe you
know
just just being there is enough how do
you feel about it
well not only do they have to focus on
it and not only is just being there not
enough but it hasn't been enough for the
past for 20 years now like they've never
really succeeded over there yeah they
they definitely like for me persona
would be like would be a good thing
because i got pc and all that but
sometimes i don't want to deal with all
the the nonsense that go along with pc
gaming sometimes the game works
sometimes they don't work but if they
can get like a complete persona
collection because they i think yes they
just got your cool over there they got
all your hands over there right yeah i
never thought that i would have saw that
either yeah and they're in game pass
get in the game yeah what's happening
and i want to point out they haven't
left game pass
yes i know i know your theories
yeah they probably won't um no no but
they should always focus on like the
eastern market and i would even argue
the european market because i'm not
saying that they aren't doing good over
there they need to do better though
cause that's what shawn is beating yeah
they got they gotta uplift all around um
i'm trying to figure out what japanese
title that i mean you know what maybe
something that i haven't seen before
something that will pique my interest
like uh project eve
we would have saw something like project
eve
i can't tell you it's third party but if
it was like let's say if it was an
exclusive title on series x or series s
that would have been dope to me because
that game does look cool
they showed her that song it's a third
party game whatever but like if
microsoft can lock up some type of
exclusivity
of a game that's kind of like that like
a bayonetta will be another one i don't
know we're on the one band that are
coming out but being that i know it's
the nintendo franchise no no bro i'm
with you you speak to my heart now cause
i'm i love platinum and i would yeah
i don't like it so me and you here yeah
yeah because you guys want that
relationship i want that relationship to
work better do something you know what's
funny is my disgust for platinum is so
high and it's not that i don't like i
just don't like their games like i i
could see they make great action-paced
games a lot of people love it i just i'm
not one of them
it's so like when i see when i saw that
eva project or whatever it's called that
was at that last event i saw that it was
immediately disgusting because i thought
it was platinum like
i was like let's get this out of here
you're like platinum
on this start like well you got to sit
on this a good
question what is going on with this plot
man last time i went to therapy it was
like 150 an hour we ain't doing that
why the hateful platinum games i don't
get it like it's weird to me so we got a
two dollar super shot from flames
bayonetta 3 is a myth like beyond good
and uh evil two yeah you're not wrong
though
that has been cancelled
uh now i think we would have we would
have probably heard something about that
if it was casual i think we would have
definitely heard something by now
because that's that's a highly
anticipated title over there so i think
we would have definitely yeah that would
have been a thing but um beyond good and
evil too this is like another one but
just like and that's what like this kind
of you know goes back to what i was
saying earlier like
this is why microsoft kind of needs
their own studios so they can cultivate
their own studio so they can have
something like oh no we got something
for y'all too yeah like we got something
we got something for y'all and and
europe like that's what i'm saying like
that's what i mean
one of the biggest issues they had with
europe is they lost the fifa licensing
like and i think that really appeals to
to that audience because they love
soccer
um you know they obviously they're not
going to get any kind of soccer games i
don't think they're going to focus on
that you know
they
i think they have the they just got to
make better than that football manager
yeah they're the football manager but
that's huge they don't really be messing
with football like that though do they
that's it but i'm gonna have that
exclusive on game pass i know people
don't but they do soccer over there they
don't do football no but it they call it
football manager but it's really oh okay
see i don't know anything about sports
exactly
clearly yeah
before you before you hit that super
chat um
okay
there was another soccer game that came
out in the early 2000s called winning
eleven eight yeah i do believe what
happened to that did fifa like do like
the madden thing where they just own all
osaka and all the good people i'm not
don't quote me because i'm not the
biggest you know
in that genre but from my understanding
it's it's fifa which i always
mispronounced and then there's there's a
second one and those two are like yeah
they're competing when chad knows the
other one those are like the competing
who's the best soccer you know i'm
saying kind of game so
i believe that's what i don't know if
that's winning 11 though i'm not sure
but check it correct me it's my european
lords
let me know what's going on now yeah i
don't know nothing about that but i know
for a fact football manager which is
technically soccer for us
is huge that that's one of sega's
biggest eyepiece
that's what he's about to say just want
to point out sega i just want to point
that out
[Laughter]
i don't
it's basically one of the biggest ips
and the fact that that is exclusively
launching in game pass is a huge deal
it's like the equivalent of like madden
you know what i'm saying oh for them
like it's a big deal and i honestly
think that's wonderful evolution soccer
i also think that's one of the reasons
that they try to be so consistent with
forza because they know that it's like
one of the only races they have over
there so they want to make sure that
those popped out pretty here here's
where i am all right like let's go i do
feel like
they need to start taking tgs just as as
important as e3 like like i think they
need to start and i'm not i'm not i
don't run a multi-trillion dollar
company i don't know but to me
you know when it comes to stuff like
let's say they did buy sega and you know
let's say that we're going to announce
it next year at e3
to me it's like
start separating these announcements to
what makes sense to these regions
sega is a big announcement for an
eastern market let that be at a tokyo
game show i get it it's a big
announcement i get it it would be very
helpful to show that at e3 get a lot of
coverage
but then you you know what you also do
on top of that you show that side of the
world you're taking them seriously like
look we had this giant news but instead
of holding it for our
side of the side of the world we want to
show it on your stage and i feel like
people would really respect that like
you know when you get these big games
like dragon quest 11 remember it was
announced at e3 or something
announced at tgs the year before instead
of waiting for e3 when you start
announcing these games at these then you
know tgs you're going to have the
demographic of people that keep not
buying your stuff they're watching that
when they're looking oh they they got
your there's probably a lot of asian
consumers that don't even know dragon
quest is on xbox
because they don't watch e3 i think it's
a fantastic point you may and i think
that along with that they've got to do
better with localization with the other
languages in the other regions because
there are a lot of regions that really
they do like xbox but if it's not in
your native language like you know it's
it's going to make you that barrier for
entry and connection and they they got
to do a better job there too but i agree
like that's a great idea like if you're
going to do a show
in these regions for example tgs you
want to cater to games and it's
exclusive and that'll be big in that
region to get the most love and to show
people in that region hey we're serious
we're not giving up on this and we're
doing a lot of things in space i think
it's great that's going to take stuff to
another part like you know
for instance when you know let's say
they do buy something like sega
something over there with a bunch of
studios to make eastern type of games to
appear to that market
now because people in the chat are
saying that you know that would never
happen
it's not happening now because they
don't have the content to put over there
constantly but if you have such a
company like sega making the next
persona making the next yakuza then
you're going you're gonna have everyone
instead of you know people in the chat
saying what are they saying about tokyo
game show i have zero expectations but
if they own sega and they know sega's
games are going to be at tgs because
that is the world that is the part of
the world that these games will appeal
to then you're going to see a completely
different tone it's kind of like how we
talked about a couple weeks ago on
building your own shows up i want every
xbox event to to expect fire there
because xbox is is that guy you know
what i'm saying like but right now it's
just like e3 or exo or video game awards
and sometimes the video game awards is
up in the air you know what i'm saying
like
that's why i respect my sony it's
besides this last one because i do feel
like it's a little lackluster i
we do always expect complete greatness
from sony with these events because for
the most part
that's what they do and you know if they
buy sega when you announce persona 6
make sure it's on tgs when you announce
the next yakuza make sure it's on tgs
when you announce these games that are
killed in these franchises make sure
it's on tgs let's say if they ever do
contract a lost audience too make sure
that's announced at tgs like sure the
western market are going to find out
the same way eastern market finds out
stuff announced at e3
through not their own stage and i get
some some western markets are going to
be upset that's not at e3 but you know
what's going to be really good when you
see a huge increase in sales on the
eastern markets because you're taking
their market seriously you're actually
showing up big at their own stages
so
anyone else let's let's talk about tgs
announcements like what is something
like we're not going to go into like
detail on like all the games you could
see that what's the one big announcement
that you could see at the tokyo game
show we'll start with hustle
persona 6. or or really some type of
persona collection i would like to see
all those together um i don't think you
can play all of those games on pcs you
want to go correct me if i'm wrong with
that i don't think that you play i think
only the third one
no fourth one yeah i think it's just the
fourth the fourth one and persona
strikers um persona 5 strikers they they
you can't play the uh persona 5 or
persona 5 royale
that type of pc announcement for me will
be like cool because i can just copy all
right and i got strikers on the piece i
just haven't played it yet but
it's the thing man um i would like to
see persona uh
they they won't do it but you know sonic
the hedgehog another song
i would say i mean because you know this
came out with sonic um
sonic colors that just came up with that
remastered so they probably won't do
that um let's see what else
uh as far as the japanese titles uh
lost judgment um if they're gonna add
anything to what they probably won't
because that just came out as a matter
of fact they probably won't talk about
that
um
nah see yeah i'm
i'm just throwing stuff against the wall
because i'm not so too familiar with the
eastern market games can somebody help
me out please no no you're good you you
said the one yeah real quick before we
go to cognito i definitely want to get
the super chat before we move on we got
a 10 super chat from bret brigham
brickham okay we're gonna move past that
i suspect bam namco would be the choice
for a japanese acquisition and recent
events increased my suspicion
increasingly enough interestingly enough
it looks like there is an xbox gundam on
the tg uh the tgs 2021 ad
look i'm not gonna go into detail
but i'm gonna just tell you something to
watch tgs like i don't want to see that
listen i'm gonna i never told i never
told you this addict like a hustler like
i am a huge i used to be like what i
used to do like you know how we you like
your favorite studios like
namco was my number one for a long time
like during especially during the
playstation era like i got an affinity
for them i kind of cooled on them a
little bit but i still i mean they're
not like my number one no more but like
they still in my top five i've always
liked them i'm a huge tekken fan i
always felt rich racing was ahead of its
time for what they did and then
obviously the anime stuff they've got
pop culture with you know all that stuff
going on there listen
i i ain't gonna lie
well i wouldn't be bad at those damn
cool man brett bring them don't stop i
don't know
i'll take it you know what i'm saying i
like it i like it we gotta
[Music]
has nine studios total with most of them
being european uh koei techno i'd
strictly uh i'd strictly japanese with
only three studios total that leaves
room to buy other japanese studios okay
i i i mess with what he's saying he's
pretty much saying like look sega makes
a lot of stuff that doesn't appeal to a
you know an asian market or eastern
market in general but he's like you know
this company they make they have three
studios that do nothing but japanese
games and on top of that you have room
to buy developers that add on to that
branch of p so it's kind of like you
know buying
let's say buying uh
finding bethesda with just you know uh
machine games and i in it and then you
know the the actual bethesda software
studios and then buying arcane and
adding on to them and buying uh the
people who make go the ghost whatever
that uh what is that game called um
which one which ghost wire
yeah adding that studio on to them so
what i would okay i'm sorry i would just
say i could actually under i i agree
with that a little bit
no i feel like i i i'm actually gonna
steal one of hustle's points
it would be dope if they
do a now where i want them to cultivate
like a new
japanese studio like uh like like
something that they got from the town
like from the you know the culture from
the area you know and let you know
either someone run it or something like
that that would be dope another one i
know it's technically not japanese i
think they're korean but so what that
that that that wu kong no
how about you
how about you put your name and back the
truck on that
kong that black myth like somebody got
to hit up that what's up the game
science team because i don't know what
sorcery they doing with their graphics
but whoo
that game looked phenomenal and it's
dark souls and i'm not a dark souls type
guy but that game looks amazing that's
something that i feel they need to be
associated with and would be a huge boom
and it and in eastern culture like that
mythos that mythology is huge like
that's a big deal what is it i think
it's called journey to the west or
whatever it is sausage knows the whole
thing
but yeah it may not exactly like you
said it it's shy maybe chinese but
correct it might be chinese but at the
end of the day you know on that side
it's a big deal i i i i agree but at the
end of the day we're trying to get the
asian market in in the entirety like
japanese shine for sure so that that
would be
look shaq future all right
good five dollar super chat from shaq
food ii
take away third party from playstation
to make xbox great is that really the
solution all right
shaq you're about to get a little
roasted man
they took away final fantasy from xbox
did that make playstation great they
took away from i mean personae never
really been on but that's a third party
game that's only on playstation is that
street fighter does that make them great
um
death loop did that make them great like
look man we can't this is the kind of
comment and i appreciate the five
dollars and i appreciate it
but it's like at the same time man we
can't act like sony doesn't do it and
only make comments on like that when
microsoft talks about doing it like we
got to keep it both on both sides we got
to how long was dragon quest an
exclusive
years it's a long time and i get you man
i get what you're saying taking third
party away from from from playstation
you want them to build up their own
studios but we just got to be realistic
here microsoft waited too long to do
this
so they're going to have to play more
like harder ball in terms of what
they're bringing into their platform to
make sure it adds up at the end
you know right now these games like you
know we always say on our laura's
podcast definitely check in this this uh
this sunday at 11 a.m eastern
but you know
we got to be real when it comes to
certain scenarios in terms of what is
going on with the the lack of games you
know we have had a decent amount of
games but look at sony sony's had death
flute sony has had uh ratchet and clank
return maternal they had demons demon
souls at the end of last year so i would
consider that because it's not been a
year
um you know they they're also getting
highly criticized successful microsoft
games such as psychonauts 2. so like at
the end of the day
sony's in a better spot i'm going to be
real with you i think microsoft is in a
spot to compete with sony in a year to
two from now but to me
yeah to me they need to start playing
more ball to snatching more of these
games out of the jaws of sony and making
sure yes what let me let me say
something right now sony got
got the world talking about an indie
game uh indie developer and envelopes
dog i'm josh suba i hyped to play kenner
like right after we're finished like
yeah no no no that xbox here they gotta
fight back man they do by almost by any
means necessary at this point
i was looking at
bandai namco's like different games that
they got
yeah you know if xbox you know get them
that's pac-man 256
[Laughter]
i i look listen i knew um i knew they
made look i knew they made dark souls
and stuff like that but i didn't and i
know that they made um tekker but it was
one of those fight games jump force
that's the joint that i ain't really
watching i wouldn't know that i want to
too much
yeah this
yeah soul calibur's there that's that's
that's that's part of my my childhood
my childhood boy i wouldn't be mad that
wouldn't be bad that's all keep going yo
can you how big with that nino cooney
too how big is that
yo if microsoft listen man i feel like
that's the one you should find
it's like ain't nothing but the slide in
the dm
so we got to find out the troopers from
michael aka best his finest there's
another uh there's another sonic
adventures in the works they'll tease it
in a little while and then also good
evening gentlemen hope all is well
once one of you just talking about sonic
you know what's crazy i keep forgetting
sega on sonic like like low-key i keep
forgetting they own that brand
so do you think you know a sonic ex
let's say they do
drop the bag off for song do you think
you think that would be relevant these
days to make an exclusive
microsoft sonic game
i think it would determine if it's good
if it's good then it can move move some
some force but if it's not good then
just don't do it i'll tell you how i'll
tell you how why it is relevant i'll
tell you how i can hit
they make it cuz you know that sonic
movie did pretty well
and part two is in production right yes
yes man they drop they drop a movie
based off their game
the movie games like back when i was
growing up and joined used to be awful
with the exception of a few like gold
now true
did i really like that no more no more
so you know we when we talk about marvel
and i mean we talk about inside mecca
how they got the marble franchise and we
just went over the whole thing
yeah no that that can work that can
definitely work in their flavor
he's back flavor's back
it's okay
sega forgets they make sonic 2.
i had that joke i had that joke lined up
but
i hope everything's going good with your
flame i hope everything's going no doubt
man
anyone got any last things about tokyo
games because i know for the most part
yeah i don't know about how so i know
kog likes a lot of the the japanese
stuff uh
but you know i don't think you keep up
with like the tokyo game show and stuff
for them yeah i'll pay attention because
like again i like them making a
concerted effort in the region i like
that phil is still serious about it and
i want to see what they do i i'm very
curious i want to see especially with
game pass and like i said sega relations
and any other little titles it'll be
good i'm not expecting crazy blockbuster
but you know if they lost as long as
they keep active just stay active in the
region i'm good you know what i mean so
we'll see we'll see what happens so
any last words from you hustle man you
got any more crazy thoughts that you
want for a tokyo game show oh here you
come
hold on
let me kill that right quick hold on let
me get out we got that two dollar super
champion
playstation buys time to exclusives not
publishers look man okay
shaq flew two we about to go at it yeah
i think you're the last one that said
this
shout out to shaq food too man i like
people that challenge stuff but don't
get disrespectful you know what i'm
saying
shaq i got i got i know this is gonna
sound just like king and i know it's
going to
playstation buys timed exclusives
because they don't have publisher money
oh wow
we're doing big bang little maintenance
make little things
let's be real here am i wrong am i wrong
they make some people could argue that
they make
the right moves as opposed to
the big book yeah well you know
microsoft sometimes spends wrong money
on big money on big moves and sometimes
sony spends less money on on you know on
smaller moves but it's the better choice
and i think once you bought earlier once
again i think it's it is a lot more in
terms of
you know
the the short term plan of the long term
plan short-term plan is what they should
be doing right now with microsoft
security type exclusives to make that
dry spot a little bit better between now
and these games start picking up and
sony sees that sony's always been
aggressive in that department and you
got to give them their hats off to that
because that doesn't that is important
when you don't really have a whole when
you're not in the news that people
aren't talking about your games for a
few
for sometimes up to six months to a year
it is going to hit that hard but you
know
anyway let's go ahead and uh wrap this
up man uh you know it's it's definitely
been a an eventful show especially acg
coming here of the uh
with the slanderer for me man he don't
like my deathbloop thoughts he said he
said it was a 10 out of six
he's definitely character so hustle
where could the people find you man and
keep in mind also he's in the
description now so every eye
you can find him
everywhere hustling motivate um youtube
and twitter hustler modem thank you to
everybody who made a donation when i was
driving in i saw what acg did acg you
probably one of the realest dudes why
the pleasure you're talking to though
straight up and down man like six
o'clock cuz jake baldino we haven't not
met yet however
it's on me the next time we see each
other onboard the show and to everybody
like yo the regulars flame and everybody
who come in this joint like that
oh yeah
more slander you know you know what's
crazy is that like
people came in here just to make fun of
my death loops
i like it i can't help it i like it
absolutely that was a good review too
you know to your credit man i saw her
yesterday i was sitting watching i said
all right
like you know i'm about to hit you up
for some time
is that what you said you know what
you're doing sounds like no no that was
dope
it was a super super dope review man
we need more of that from you too um no
but thank everybody for joining us you
know i'm still humbled by the fact that
you know attic you know he he found me
on the curb he said
he said you said no come on got you off
the block baby we got you on the block
yeah he did man you know if it wasn't
for
you know
i wouldn't i wouldn't know the boys over
there so like that's that's it always
mean a lot and i'm sorry i gotta end
this show like this but i appreciate
that and everybody else in there i see
xbot in there i see a lot of people in
the chat right now we appreciate y'all
y'all make sure y'all come back next
week hopefully i'll be on time and i'll
have to work overtime no more hopefully
i will be on top no no no i'm mad
because they asked me at the last minute
that's why i'm good bro you're good no
no this is
this this is fun i'm like i said i'm
kicking myself a little bit because i
missed the show but nah thank you thank
you for joining us
you know it's like i said man it's five
minutes yeah you didn't miss much like
you missed maybe you're killing yourself
for that five minutes i respect i
respect it you know at the end of the
day
when we decided because you know me and
cole were talking about
you know who would be the co-host for a
while because people didn't know it but
i was actually i was i was i was trying
people out
and you know it just it's like i said
last week man you know i gotta have the
chemistry i got to have the passion and
the availability and a lot of the times
you get one or the other or so like it's
very hard to find all three and you have
all three correct corrections so called
needle what's yo what what's going on
with that defining duke man what's up
well we dropped off dropped a banger
which out the bang i just wrapped up
ultimate with um i'll give you a little
sneak preview
hulk and uh your hulk jumped on we
talked about that destiny situation with
mario o'donnell he's getting dirty the
mud is slinging it's it's getting crazy
out there in these streets so definitely
check that out that should go up
hopefully tomorrow and then i got
another one cooking with maddie tomorrow
and then yeah last word this friday come
check us out it's gonna be thursday
there's a trouble check us out paul
tassie's pulling up that'll be lit we're
gonna talk about what's going on with
that and then you know the realm is back
on sunday you know we do you know what i
said so yeah it's luke everybody i'm
glad to come in phil off the bench every
once in a while when i have time hold it
down you know what i'm saying my man
hustle pulled up you already know and
it's funny so with everybody that pulled
up man it's good to see i love attic
doing this thing his show his vision i'm
just along for the ride you know just
chilling i like that i don't got a hoax
i just come in here and talk and
disagree and yell at him and it's fun
like i said for you guys ben i got that
death loop
uh review definitely go to check out
that out you know then you'll uh see why
what's funny is people think like i have
the like you know some crazy opinion on
death loop well you like watch that
opinion you'll see i have a lot like you
know similar pin that a lot of other
people do uh you know definitely catch
iop this uh sunday at 11 a.m
unfortunately
let me make sure i didn't miss any super
chats
so we got a 10 super chat from kaden
forever here's a list of independent
studios available plus games they make
silicon studio bravery default oh that's
independent oh i like that
arcadia studio street fighter 2 creator
i don't know what that's about
hexa drive wonderful 101 co-developer
oh
and then god fill mario war uh warrior
so they're making like some license
stuff that's cool then we got a five
dollar super chat uh
look i don't want kate forever
they do you guys i like that bravery
default actually i want to talk about
this for a couple seconds okay i want
them to pick up that silicon for for
make a game like bravery default because
i feel like that's that's a good thing
like a lot of people don't get bravery
you know what there's interviews with
square enix after the success of the
first bravery default where they said
they that square enix said that they
gonna have to go back to the drawing
boards and how they approach rpgs
because of that game really
really oh it got an effect it affected
them in that because they saw the
success
oh wow that's what's up i didn't know
that uh so you know and then there
apparently this arcana studio has made
street fighter 2
creator so i'm assuming that's a head
fighter
uh do you
you think if they can't get something
like netherrealm they should get a
smaller studio and build up to making
haddad fighters
they need somebody to hit the fighting
genre that's all i want because it gives
somebody the rights to um kill instinct
we can't let that thing just sit there
you know what i mean so yeah whatever
whatever get the talent get the talent
man for sure all right so that's pretty
much in there that warrior uh warrior
where i i don't really
mess with nintendo games a whole whole
lot i know i was just uh finishing that
super chat
then we got uh
uh
christian
with the five dollar super chat maybe
we'll get the final fantasy pixel
remastered and final fantasy 7 remake on
game faster
yeah you do if you wanna i don't know if
sony i think we we we we're gonna assume
sony may have secretly extended that
final fantasy 7 but i would love that
pixel really
yeah that would be fine and then we got
a five dollar super chat from gamer by
choice great show
team salute appreciate it gabriel by
choice shout out to him man he's been
here you know i am going to let you guys
on a little secret i know you guys have
noticed that you've had like the little
king icon beside the members for a while
uh there is a two-year one that if you
if you've been a member for i think two
years and some of you have uh i'm going
to talk and have that king because
the two-year icon's empty right now
because it won't be real with you guys
gonna be real with you i didn't think
there would be a year
so you just do it you know
so i'm going to have about we gonna make
that
so i'm gonna talk to i'm gonna get
someone to make uh an iop logo for the
two-year people so you have an iop logo
beside your name and i think that would
be cool i appreciate everyone coming
through man we had up to like 360 50
people
you guys have been mad generous with the
super chats i appreciate that uh you
know it and we'll be here next tuesday
me and hustle will be talking about
whatever happens between now and then
i'm hoping that something happens but
even if it doesn't matter we'll just
wing it like we always do man we'll wing
it
i appreciate everyone for coming through
we will see you